good morning John it's question Tuesday
on Friday the day that we answer real
questions from real nerdfighters go what
countries is nerdfighteria bigger than
ah who are you I'm the you that ask the
questions no that's not normal yeah I
don't think that we do normal like the
last video you did you use the phrase
passive-aggressive robot sack of ketchup
pee and the one before that was about
cat gifs did you to say gifts because we
say gifs not that either of those are
incorrect
yeah actually I'm think about changing
because the president used gif in one of
his speeches well I'm not thing about
changing and you're me
yeah that's not uh whatever what
countries is nerdfighteria bigger than
well that have been on how you count
I've done some research on this topic
and if you counting by the number of
people who watch regularly we are bigger
than 61 countries including the Barbados
and if you count by the number of people
subscribed we're bigger than 85
countries including Djibouti which has
the smallest population of all countries
in Africa it also contains the lowest
point in all of Africa the shores of
Lake asau are more than 500 feet below
sea level oh that is just got used to
the question asking me who lack are you
I'm useless trivia you did you know that
volleyball was invented as a safer
alternative to basketball in the 1890s
no of course I didn't know that no one
knew that thoughts on YouTube paid
subscriptions yeah I don't know how
people are gonna end up using them
hopefully in innovative and interesting
ways I am in favor of people being able
to make money from the content they
produce but I will tell you that John
and I will never put our content behind
a paywall did you know that the first
picture uploaded to the Internet was of
an all-female comedy group based at the
CERN laboratory in Switzerland his
Batman really is superhero or just a
super rich guy I mean there are a lot of
super rich guys that didn't become
Batman I would almost venture to say the
Batman is more of a superhero than other
superheroes cuz he doesn't have anything
that makes him super special he doesn't
have any mystical super powers he just
has a bunch money
cousin Larry from perfect strangers
would have played a villain called man
back and the cancelled follow-up to the
George Clooney Batman movie Wow you are
both amazing
and terrible can you teach me how to
dougie no again I can know how to do the
dougie how can light be affected by
black holes if it has no mass well Hank
gravity is actually an interaction
between objects with energy and momentum
which light hats was I just momentarily
replaced by the god 4 minute physics
also did you know that he's actually a
really good mandolin player Marvel or DC
Dark Horse Stan Lee's birth name is Stan
Lee just to be clear all the extra Hanks
in this video did not streamline the
process so yeah two question Tuesday's
in one week what I will say though mine
was a little bit more ambitious but the
best answers of this week's question
Tuesday's those definitely go to nerd
factory like Patrick McGuire who said
that if he were invisible he would go to
Paris and beat up a mind but not to be
mean
no because the applause that he would
get the recognition would be astounding
and then there's Rachel's take on the
Great Gatsby film quoting Gatsby saying
whenever you feel like criticizing
anyone just remember that all the people
in this world have not had the
advantages that you've had critique on
the movie thus being that the people who
created it must not have had the same
advantages she had in having read the
book and then there's the vampires here
who is excited about ferrets they
totally are tiny dog honors thanks turn
fight area you guys are good at
answering questions you should feel free
to answer the questions that I just
answered even though there weren't that
many of them because all the whip
panning thanks to all the people who
helped with that Henry from
minutephysics Stefan and Emily and
Michael or all in this room while we
were doing that John don't do a question
Tuesday next Tuesday cuz that would
definitely be overkill
I'll see you that takes me how to good
taste meets me how to good taste me how
to drug taste meets me